Fox News is now targeting John
fetterman's wife this is a real study in
character assassination as carried out
by the American right wing and media
apparatus let's look at the clip's first
and then I'm going to explain
um Aaron rupar assembled what was a
roughly 24-hour period
of attacks on Giselle fetterman take a
look at this
partially cropped out
and accused Mrs fetterman of using it
for her own 15 minutes of fame okay so
so far it's all fun and games right but
let's continue uh one critic said she
wanted this so badly for herself LOL
another first day for Senator elect
Gisele fetterman and why is she even
there your thoughts
well she's a lot better looking than he
is so as a man who's married to a wife
that is far better looking I'm sure John
fetterman would say I don't even need to
be in this photo but he's not able to do
the job Harris and uh and the reality
here is that it does feel as if
basically Pennsylvania has elected his
life and she certainly is furthering
that idea uh with these photos maybe
she's going to step down oh so even
though it's a joke there's still a truth
in this and now listen to this
conspiracy theory I'll back up back it
up a few seconds his wife and she
certainly is furthering that idea uh
with these photos maybe she's gonna step
down and the new democrat governor-elect
is going to end up appointing her when
her husband can't do the job uh what I I
still am so embarrassed that we could
ever be in a situation where John
fetterman got elected in Pennsylvania
it's an utter failure of pennsylvanians
that he's their representative well look
uh every Republican uh lawmaker that's
dissecting this that your interview will
tell you that they're going to take a
close look at how polling was wrong they
really want to know what happened not
just in this race because what happened
is Oz lost that's what happened so max
Kennerly explains the mechanism that is
at play here Fox does it and many do it
okay this is Max writes this segment is
a case study of the four-part Fox News
method number one pick a villain
preferably a woman and or minority
Giselle immigrated from Brazil okay
that's number one number two find
something innocuous the fettermans have
a long-running gag about John not
fitting in pictures so the fact that in
the picture she posted John fetterman is
only partially in the picture it's a
known gag it's a thing that they've had
going for a while it's it's just a joke
okay then Max counterly goes on to
explain number three is you reframe the
innocuous thing as contemptible
and the fact that John fetterman only
partially is in the picture even though
it's a long-running joke is because
Giselle is self-centered it's because
maybe she's really in charge it's maybe
because fetterman can't do the job
because of his stroke Etc and then part
four is you inject that completely
deranged conspiracy theory which is John
is actually incapacitated and there's a
plot for him to resign and then Josh
Shapiro who defeated Doug mastriano to
become the next Governor will appoint
Giselle fetterman to be the next senator
from Pennsylvania that's that's the
four-part system
that's really what's contemptible and
unfortunately because you and I we
understand the parts and we go okay
here's how they go from one to two to
three to four a lot of the Fox News
viewers will just focus on that last
thing yeah you know what this is a plot
fetterman can't do the job because of
the stroke
and so this is all to make Giselle
fetterman an immigrant from Brazil woman
of color a senator even though she
wasn't elected there's no evidence for
that obviously uh this stuff works Max
counterly doing a good job of explaining
how
the chances that your login credentials
have been leaked in a data breach are
higher than you might think but you can
actually check if you go to aura.com
Pacman you can try Aura for free our
sponsor Aura scans the dark web for your
personal information login credentials
social security number and sends you
alerts sign up and you could be shocked
to see how many alerts you get on Aura
one of our team members found his login
credentials in three different data
breaches now of course he changed his
passwords right away I've told you
before about one of my accounts getting
hacked scary feeling but Aura also does
so much more by automatically requesting
the removal of information from data
search engines giving you fast alerts on
suspicious credit inquiries or it has
password management malware protection
for all of your devices and Aura also
helps you manage what your kids can do
on their devices by restricting certain
apps it's really like a Swiss army knife
of online security and you can try Aura
for free for two weeks at aura.com
Pacman the link is down below